[Music]
this looks like manager baguette also
this o is too
big also also the daily mail also also
also these limey bastards throwing shade
at gertie's toffee apples they're
delicious you leave her alone what's the
matter haven't you ever seen a talking
snowman before this tongue-in-cheek
reference to the absurdity we're all
about to witness only serves to make me
feel like i'm being gaslighted by a
snowman here's where we grew up and
whose dumb job is it to haul boxes of
decorations out to the woods to decorate
the trees christmas seals no i'm pretty
sure those are just regular seals who
just happen to enjoy celebrating
christmas and christmas seals are
actually an old-timey envelope sticker
used to raise money for charitable
organizations so i'm giving this a sin
because i think that cheeky snowman knew
that whoever heard of a skinny santa eat
eat i haven't but i have heard of
diabetes high cholesterol and heart
disease so i'm gonna say that mrs claus
doesn't quite have her priorities in
order now don't any of you worry your
heads about santa mrs claus will have
him plenty fattened up by christmas eve
i'm pretty sure no child cares about
santa's weight they care about presents
i mean now they may care about someone
else's body fat percentage but they
didn't before you brought it up so sit
on you he's
he's got a shiny nose and while we're
pointing out things that aren't normally
on reindeer you have pink eyelids blushy
cheeks and thick maybe it's maybelline
eyelashes but that doesn't seem to be
concerning what is the line for alarming
visual abnormalities on a reindeer well
we'll simply have to overlook it we all
know this nose will ultimately win him
fame and fortune but considering the way
everyone reacts to this deformity and
the fact that this is a newborn
overlooking this seems negligent i mean
at least take him to the doctor for a
first opinion after all if he's going to
be on my team someday he'd better get to
know me well i feel like it's enough to
send the writers for not thinking this
is a creepy statement i challenge you
for a moment to imagine your child's
little league coach showing up to their
birth and saying this so the biggest sin
here and for most of the show to be
honest is bad parenting i'm sure it'll
stop as soon as he grows up santa well
let's hope so if he wants to make the
sleigh team someday santa basically
saying i'd love to promote you on merit
but i only choose the most
reindeer and quite frankly i can't stand
the look of your face
every year i shine up my jingle bells
for eight lucky reindeer well it seems i
jumped the shark too soon with regard to
the santa having sex with the reindeer
angle that being said clean bells is the
least he can do and this christmas hole
wants a medal for it most important of
all he taught his son to be aware of
the abominable snow monster of the north
pitty though obvious antlers are obvious
you see all the toys santa brings are
made by
these elves there's another term for
free labor like that that surprisingly
shares a lot of the same letters as
elves and if you said interns you're not
entirely wrong but you are illiterate
and surprisingly versed in ethical
economics seems elves have that certain
knack for toy making what knack might
that be this guy's just whacking his
wood with his hammer i don't see a nail
a dowel or anything all except for this
this one misfit we now derail your story
about rudolph to introduce you to a
character that no one will remember in
50 years there's a pile up a mile wide
behind you pretty sure he actually means
a mile long the only place you can get
into a pile up a mile wide is houston
but more importantly there is no pile up
that anyone can see here finish the job
or you're fired wait they can get fired
i was positive the elves were being held
against their will but if they can get
fired surely they can quit
oh okay so there's really nothing
stopping herme here from setting up the
small unlicensed dental practice now
instead of at the end of the show also
this story is leaning hard on the
laughable idea of a white blonde-haired
dennis being persecuted for who he is
all right son try it on i don't wanna
daddy i don't like it you'll like it and
wear it the safe sex psa i was forced to
watch in high school somehow makes its
way into the show and to this day i'm
still scared my parents are going to
want to have the talk is
is the snowman wearing gloves to keep
his hands warm well let's get this over
with i have to go down and look over the
new deer we all know you don't have to
but you want to and the wanna and the
tua and the three
elves then proceed to sing in perfect
harmony and this little elf equips back
with that sounded terrible the tenor
section was weak and it was not the
shenanigans were uncalled for but the
harmony was on point also since singing
doesn't seem like a skill required to
make toys and santa is ultimately in
charge it's pretty weird for him of all
people to be annoyed with his high
school musical masquerading as elf
practice this [ __ ] is standing on his
instrument if you're gonna throw down
crunchy grooves you gotta respect your
tools man we have dolls that cry talk
walk blink and run a temperature up to
this point i thought all the toys were
old timey you know may not a wooden this
guy just dropped a bunch of info about
the tack they're building into these
things and after all that the show still
wants me to believe they can't just
attach some fog lights to santa sleigh i
think you're cute making children think
the power of boners has a causal
relationship to a reindeer's ability to
fly donner you should be ashamed of
yourself right how dare you allow your
seed to gestate a freak of nature such
as this he had a nice takeoff too the
breeding process is apparently going so
well that this [ __ ] has no use for a
flying reindeer it makes about as much
sense as colonel phillips having so
little use for a super soldier that he
sends captain america off to sell war
bonds it's terrible it's different from
everybody else's but that's what makes
it so grand why any doe would consider
herself lucky to be with you i'm
beginning to think the writers actually
wrote this whole screenplay as a
metaphor about rudolph's
no dove mind is going to be seen with a
a red-nosed reindeer this feels racist
but i don't know if having a red nose is
considered to be a different race among
reindeer so maybe it's all fascist who
are you
well actually i am a dentist rudolph
said who not what and even then you
aren't your job well i am a pedantic ass
and that is most of my job so maybe some
people are their jobs but the point is
we just met and i just want your name no
one cares that you work in finance brad
hey what do you say we both be
independent together huh libertarians
this is my land white people in the
1700s i don't know much about
prospecting but the fervor with which
he's licking that pickaxe leads me to
believe this oral fixation has nothing
to do with it with my eyes i see sam the
snowman playing a banjo in the scene but
with my ears and my soul i detect no
banjo cornelius is using a wiener dog on
his sleigh team why
how
and why
mom dad i wanna watch a show about
rudolph sure kids looks calm enough yeah
[ __ ] em up why would cornelius opt for
this really dangerous version of a
rescue instead of no i don't know
shooting the monster in the knee with
his gun do it yourself
climate change no this is man's work man
the bigotry is strong with this one i
think if he could just pump the brakes
on the sexism for a moment he'd realize
this is not work at all this is taking
responsibility for your child donner i
find it very concerning that cornelius
rudolph and hermie arrive on an island
of misfit toys without any of the dogs
and no one seems to notice they ate them
didn't they oh a water pistol and shoots
jelly i was under the assumption that
manufacturing defects were the thing
that made you a misfit toy this is just
a temporary condition if this water
pistol fires off enough shots the
problem will eventually resolve itself
also someone else deciding to fill you
with jelly is not your fault unlike clay
things a living creature cannot hide
himself on an island um they aren't
trying to hide they're trying to live
here the lion king seems to be unaware
of the fact that a lot of people just
live on islands that night he decides to
strike out on his own and leave the door
wide open rudolph is a deer dick to dear
ducks because everyone in this room is
going to have frostbite when they wake
up thanks to him how does he not know
that you can quietly escape by turning
the handle first as you gently close the
door and then slowly release the handle
once the doors completely sealed the
threshold
thing was happening show momentarily
makes me believe the strange and
wonderful thing was going to involve a
deer's hole this is not how sledding
works
ah hermes just removed all of notorious
asm's teeth without anesthetic and the
show plays this is a cute resolution
what in the literal [ __ ] is going on
show has already established that he's
no longer a threat but the writers felt
now would be a good time for yukon corey
elenas to attack this defensiveless
creature and push them off a [ __ ]
cliff bumbles bound i don't give a [ __ ]
if they bounce i reform this bumble this
claim of reformation when i'm not even
convinced the abdominal morocca was a
threat to begin with he hasn't heard
anyone other than the time he dropped a
big rock on rudolph but at the time
rudolph was trying to shove antlers up
his chimney seems defensible to me
you're gonna disappoint the children
they expect a fat santa what is with
this tension regarding whether or not
santa's going to be fat on christmas i
have to say this is the weirdest will
there won't they cliche i've ever come
across that beautiful wonderful nose
appreciating someone only after finding
out you can exploit their talents
that's my santa oh thanks mama weird
foreplay aside this is a terrifyingly
absurd amount of weight to gain in one
night and first i thought this lazy ass
santa was using umbrella parachutes
instead of taking the toys down to the
houses himself but then i realized that
this evil [ __ ] elf was just
discarding the misfit toys again like
paratroopers behind enemy lines the
darkness of this show has broken the
little child that was living quite
comfortably in my psyche
i loved a woman who wasn't clean mrs
santa that was her sister
okay people tomorrow morning 10 a.m
santa's coming to town
oh my god pull up an ice block and lend
an ear
all right all right
i look around i see these young faces
and i think i mean
i made every wrong choice a middle-aged
man can make i pissed away all my money
i chased off
anyone who's ever loved me
and lately
i can't even stand the face i see in a
mirror
my name's clarice hi
you use heavier skin cream and sometimes
you wear leather tongue
but not today
long as thick as peanut butter no sir mr
peanut butter please mr peanut butter
was my father's name
hey
looky up there it's a bird it's a plane
jingle jingle jingle you will hear my
sleigh bells ring
i am old chris kringle i'm the king of
jingling first of his name
king of the angles and the first men and
lord of the seven kingdoms
hey are you awake
yeah i just want you to know i hate you
and so is my dad well that's fine cause
guess what i hate you too and this house
sucks ass
ready rudolph the partridge is in the
pear tree we are go for launch vehicle
dash away engines dash away partridge
dash away dash away oh
you are a toy